das ist eine echte premiere ein
forschungsteam aus götting hat eine
galaxie aufgespürt die gleich drei
supermassereiche schwarze löcher in
ihrem zentrum beherbergt alle drei
befinden sich in kosmischen dimensionen
gesehen sehr eng beieinander und die
ursache für dieses phänomen die ist
absolut verblüffend tricks um science
fiction die spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's sie bekommen es geht um dass
galaxien system mit der bezeichnung ngc
62 40 von dem man bisher dachte dass
sich in seinem zentrum zwei
supermassereiche schwarze löcher
befinden
doch jetzt ist klar dass es sogar drei
giganten sind die der kern dieser
galaxie beherbergt und das ist eine
echte seltenheit denn normalerweise
enthält jede galaxie in ihrem zentrum
ein schwarzes loch ein schwarzes loch wo
unter anderem auch unsere milchstraße
das nun aufgespürte dreifach system ist
also eine wirklich überraschende und
spektakuläre entdeckung möglich wurde
sie durch das very large telescope der
europäischen südsternwarte in chile
eingesetzt wurde der 3d news
spektrograph in kombination mit vier
künstlich erzeugten laser sternen und
einem speziellen optik system so kamen
bilder zustande
die bezüglich ihrer schärfe an bilder
des weltraumteleskops hubble
heranreichen doch zusätzlich lieferte
der spektrograph von jedem bild pixel
auch ein spektrum so dass die massen und
die bewegung der drei schwarzen löcher
in der galaxie ngc 62 40 genau bestimmt
werden konnten dazu der astrophysiker
wolfram kolat schnee aus göttingen durch
unsere beobachtung mit extrem hoher
räumlicher auflösung waren wir in der
lage zu zeigen dass sich im zentrum des
wechsel wirkenden galaxien systems ngc
62 40 anstatt zwei wie bisher vermutet
in wirklichkeit gleich drei
supermassereiche schwarze löcher
befinden
jedes einzelne der drei masse giganten
verfügt über eine masse von mehr als 90
millionen sonnen wow
die analysen zeigen dass sich die
schwarzen löcher dennoch sehr eng
beieinander befinden und zwar in einer
raum region von weniger als 3000
lichtjahren das entspricht nicht einmal
einem hundertstel der gesamten
ausdehnung dieser
galaxien astronomische dimensionen
gesehen ist das also tatsächlich ein
eher kleines areal in dem sich die
schwergewichte drängeln äußerst
ungewöhnlich auch die entdeckung dass
die beiden südlichen schwarzen löcher
sogar nur 645 lichtjahre voneinander
entfernt sind und in der zukunft werden
sie sich wohl sogar noch weiter annähern
bis sie dann letztendlich verschmelzen
erste gravitationswellen die durch die
gegenseitigen wechselwirkungen entstehen
könnten aber schon in einigen millionen
jahren zustande kommen nach angaben der
fachleute handeln sie sich bei diesem
trio aber bereits jetzt um den bisher
engsten bekannten fall dazu der physiker
peter wählbarer der an der aktuellen
studie beteiligt war eine derartige
konzentration von drei supermassereichen
schwarzen löchern wurde im universum
bisher noch nie entdeckt der vorliegende
fall liefert hinweise auf die simultane
verschmelzung von ursprünglich drei
galaxien mitsamt ihren zentralen
schwarzen löcher die fachleute sind
optimistisch die zeitliche entwicklung
von galaxien durch diese entdeckung
besser zu verstehen
entstanden ist das dreifach system
nämlich wahrscheinlich durch einen
simultanen verschmelzungsprozess eine
dreier koalition könnte auch das
schnelle wachstum von galaxien erklären
dass forschungsteams weltweit bislang
noch ein rätsel war bislang die man
davon aus dass galaxien nach und nach
kleineren nachbargalaxien aufnehmen und
somit wachsen
doch wie können dann gigantische
galaxien riesen zustande gekommen sein
die schon im frühen kosmos existierten
und für solch einen allmählichen
wachstumsprozess eigentlich gar keine
zeit hatten dazu der astrophysiker peter
wallbacher wenn es jedoch auch zu
simultanen verschmelzungsprozesses
mehrerer galaxien kam konnten sich die
größten galaxien mit ihren zentralen
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern
wesentlich schneller entwickeln unsere
beobachtungen liefern den ersten hinweis
auf dieses szenario wie sieht ein
schwarzes loch aus anklicken anschauen
und den ziemlich coolen kanal tracking
abbonieren bis dann bleibt dran